lo que quiero realizar en este vídeo es
empezar con una forma abstracta de la
fórmula que conocemos o llamamos la
regla de la cadena y luego aprenderemos
a aplicarla usando una forma un poquito
más concreta así que empecemos con una
con alguna función con una expresión que
pueda verse como el producto de dos
funciones o una composición de dos
funciones y las vamos a expresar como f
deje x f de g de x entonces es una
función expresada como una composición
de dos funciones y dejan aquí pongo del
mismo color para que estén acorde no
surjan confusiones y entonces nos
interesa tomar la derivada respecto de x
de este ejemplo entonces lo que haría la
regla de la cadena lo que nos dice es
que esto va a ser igual a la derivada de
nuestra función
efe con respecto a la función con la que
está compuesta y nosotros podemos
escribir esto como f prima f prima pero
no de x sino de lo que está compuesto
adentro que sería de g x
por la derivada de nuestra función
interior o bien la composición pero
respecto de x que se viaje prima de x y
todo esto es meramente abstracto yo creo
que quedaría más claro si lo aplicamos
en un ejemplo real entonces aquí tenemos
la derivada respecto de x y vamos a
poner la siguiente función que sería la
raíz cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de 3x
cuadrada menos x y quizás a quien es muy
claro cómo está la composición por lo
que yo creo que sería adecuado poner de
otra forma estas dos funciones y
entonces para que esto esté claro espero
ustedes de acuerdo vamos a poner acá a
fx que sea la raíz de equis y de otro
color de color amarillo para que las
identifique agv x que sería como lo que
está dentro 3 x cuadrada menos x y éstas
las vamos a ir desarrollando poco a poco
y vamos a poner por acá abajo la
composición que sería f
gx y lo vamos a poner de amarillo y
entonces esto queda de la siguiente
forma tenemos que esto sería igual a la
derivada de fx que sea la derivada de la
raíz de x en este caso pues no tenemos a
x verdad sino ag de xy estoy haciendo
como un pequeño truco espero logres
verlo porque no es precisamente la
composición x no es la otra función
entonces aquí nos queda la raíz de 3x
cuadrada menos x
entonces ya al seguir estos pasos que es
lo que queremos llegar y si primero
nosotros encontramos fx de esta forma y
gx en su otra forma quizás nos resulte
más sencillo y será justo lo suficiente
entonces ahora si aplicamos la regla de
la cadena donde sé que esto sería f
prima de x y ésta sea la derivada de f
con respecto de x entonces esto lo
podemos escribir como x a la un medio
que corresponde a lo mismo si tenemos
raíz de x y al realizar la derivada nos
queda un medio
a la 1 menos un medio que esto queda un
medio negativo y esta es la derivada de
f prima de x entonces acá abajo es lo
mismo que si ponemos f prima de dicha
composición deje de x entonces
reescribiendo lo aquí abajito para que
nos quede más claro sería un medio de la
composición y de adentro a la menos un
medio entonces aquí escribo de color
amarillo gdx para que no se confunda
cada vez esto es igual igual a tener voy
a agarrar el mismo color un medio de gx
donde eje x corresponde a 3x cuadrada
menos x e igual de igual forma se eleva
a la menos un medio simplemente lo
estamos reescribiendo pero al final es
exactamente lo mismo que nosotros
tenemos por aquí que sería f prima de
eje x es igual a esto de acá entonces
los voy a encerrar en este rectángulo
para ir identificando pero déjame lo
escribes de un color diferente al
amarillo porque luce demasiado entonces
en este rectángulo verde es lo mismo que
tenemos por acá vamos a ir identificando
las partes
para ir dándole un mejor formato a esto
entonces quedamos que esto es efe primer
eje x de la composición que sería un
medio de la composición a la menos un
medio y aquí adentro igual 3x cuadrada
menos x y también lo voy a encerrar de
color verde para que lo identifique y
ahora vamos por otro lado hay que tomar
ahora la derivada de la composición que
en este caso quede x representa el 3 x
cuadrada menos x en este caso resulta un
poco más sencillo pues es la derivada de
eje de x entonces donde x ahora es este
valor que está por aquí ya no estamos
haciéndolo como respecto de alguna
función sino ya son los simples valores
entonces que prima de x respecto a la
regla de la potencia en este caso va a
ser 2 por 13-6 x menos 1 eso se viaje
prima de x entonces acá lo voy a
escribir abajo 6 x menos 1 que está
multiplicando a la derivada anterior y
está en esta ocasión lo encerraremos del
color azul para que identifiques qué es
y lo hemos hecho solamente aplicamos la
regla de la potencia y como repaso esto
que está por acá su derivada es un medio
de 3x cuadrada menos x a la menos un
medio que a su vez está multiplicada por
la derivada de la composición que en
este caso fue 6 x menos 1 y listo hemos
acabado